live this is good day las vegas
4 46 here on a tuesday morning netflix
is giving fans a glimpse into the life
and career of the notorious b.i.g
it's the first documentary about the
rapper actually approved by his estate
it features interviews from his mother
and close friends like sean diddy combs
biggie i got a story to tell is what
it's called and it streams on netflix
march 1st sherry a lot of documentaries
out right now
well if music is your love language and
you're still searching for that perfect
match
now there's an app for that a relatively
new dating app is
using your music taste to make a match
the idea really came because i saw my
friends and family struggling on sort of
the more traditional dating apps
where it was just sort of perpetual
swiping and
you know these same people were huge
music fans like i am
and so i saw this opportunity to create
a dating app that would work for them
well rachel van nortwick she launched
vinyly app
in the apple store that was in october
of 2019
just a few months before the pandemic
kit the app shows your spotify listing
history
and questions about music like who you
first saw in concert
and other questions then it matches you
with others based on your music taste
the app is free on the apple store and
you'll and it'll be available on the
google play store
very soon so i don't know you guys i
mean can you really
find your love match through your taste
in music yeah i believe what they are
all going to end up suggesting is that
you end up dating spotify
because spotify truly knows you better
than anybody right alex
you heard me i yeah yeah well
you know they always say music is a love
language for some and
if you have the same taste i guess it
could work um
also saying who your first concert was
that'll give your age away real quick so
that'll help you weed out
is not just having the same things in
common with music but learning other
stuff
because i know my music knowledge is all
over the map compared with someone else
who might be more interested in
i don't know spoken word or something
something weird classical
can work classy john yeah
well it's an interesting idea though
yeah it is better to know that
that uh you know you're getting together
with a metal head
and you like yanny
[Laughter]